i would like to welcome those who have
just joined we'll be starting today's uh
webinar in more 10 minutes thank you for
joining
and meanwhile we begin with today's
webinar it would be great to hear from
you about your educational background
and also your research interests
so you can put them in the chat box
looking forward to it thank you
thank you
thank you everyone uh for joining we'll
be just starting in two more minutes we
are waiting for others to join as well
thank you
i would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar where we will discuss
about our upcoming summer programs and
the opportunity to get trained and work
on an independent research project with
mentor guidance
i'm sunalika ri and i'm the omixlogic
community manager and i'm responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of our
bioinformatics community that is managed
by buying biotech
to talk about the flow of today's
webinar we will first discuss about
omixlogic metagenomics training program
which will commence on may 23rd
metagenomics is relatively a new field
of research based on high throughput
sequencing on next generation sequencing
and its popularity signifies a growing
appreciation for the composition of
microbial communities and the genetic
information their genomes carry
metagenomics allows us to study the
microbiome in its natural environment
and learn about the cooperative and
often symbiotic relationships between
prokaryotes eukaryotes viruses and
archaea
in this metagenomics or mix logic
specialization we will explore how
different types of analysis can be used
to understand the microbial world we
will cover several bioinformatics
approaches to the analysis of the
microbiome we will learn to compare
microbial composition in different
conditions learn about the sequencing of
viral samples and discuss how microbes
await the immune response of the host as
well as evade treatment we will do so in
the context of several projects taken
from high impact publications
next in the webinar we'll discuss about
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
which will commence on may 17th this
program is dedicated to studying the
viral diversity and its role in epidemic
infectious diseases that keeps
re-emerging including zoonotic spillover
transmission between hosts and humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease development
the participants will get a chance to
learn about bioinformatics and analyze
genomic data by applying various
analysis approaches to study viral
genomes
as a result you will learn to understand
the relationships between viral strains
and haprotypes find differences in
sequence data and see the implications
for drug and vaccine design this program
will provide opportunities to practice
analyzing data to gain hands-on
experience with curated data sets from
public domain collections which are
present in these example projects guided
by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about virology
later we will also discuss about other
upcoming summer programs which includes
precision oncology or mixed logic
genomics chem informatics for biomedical
drug discovery and also will discuss
about the summer research internship or
the fellowship program
we would discuss about these programs
with you how joining these programs in
summer can help you get into your dream
degree in the fall or upscale your
skills for better career opportunities
and finally how you can join these
programs and learn from experts
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
so now let's quickly sign up on the
honest logic learn portal just to make
sure that we have the access to the
resources that we are going to cover
today so i just share the link to the
portal once again and share my screen
yes
so here is the link in the chat box
please make sure that you all have an
account on the omixlogic learn portal so
that it's easier for you to follow the
resources that we are going to cover
today i just quickly give you a demo on
how you can have your account on the
omixlogic loan portal for free for those
who already have an account you can just
put one in the chat box and others can
follow the process along with me just to
make sure that you have an account and
if you face any technical issues then we
are here to assist you
so you can just simply click on the
login button on the top right and then
you'll get some options by which you can
have your own account either create your
account by putting in the credentials
that are required or simply sign up with
any of your social media accounts i'll
be using my google account for the same
uh please let me know in the chat if you
have an account already and if not then
you can create one and let us know that
you have done so
right
next what we want to do is to have an
updated profile so the next steps for
those who have already created their
accounts or are doing so
please update your profile you need to
click on your mail id in the menu bar
itself this will lead you to a profile
section now joining these programs will
give you an access to the omixlogic
resources which includes the coursework
and also the session recordings so it's
very important for you to go through
these resources and most importantly
monitor your progress and also uh having
an updated profile helps us monitor your
progress timely so please make sure that
you have an updated profile picture your
name should be in title case this is the
same format that will reflect on your
certificates that you will get in the
profile section itself once your
particular course work is complete
please make sure that you link your
social media accounts and also add a
brief bio about yourself that could
include about your educational research
background and also your research
interests so that it's easier for us to
guide you and also for the mentor to
know about your research and trust
it's very important to make sure that
you have the starter subscription active
as a part of the program and also the
badge of the program should be added to
your profile
so that was what i wanted to discuss
with you about signing up on the portal
and also updating your profile now you
are all set to go through the resources
on the portal
i would now like to invite
mr elia brotsky
who is going to take you through these
programs metagenomics and bioinformatics
for infectious diseases as well
india is a ceo and co-founder and has a
background in bioinformatics data
science project management and
commercial product development mr
brodsky has facilitated and also managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma rnd
teams he also
oversees many of these scientific
projects to talk about this uh important
area of metagenomics analysis and
sequencing now i would like to pass on
the stage to mr india over to you
thank you very much america
and so what i'll do in my part of the
presentation i'll start by introducing
the omixlogic program and then i will
pass it on to dr raghav who is going to
be speaking about his
kind of
detailed review of the curriculum and
the types of exercises and projects that
we will conduct
so the omics logic metagenomics program
is a program designed to introduce the
participants to the role of the microbes
but also to the practical aspects of
data analysis to understand from data
generation to processing to downstream
biological interpretation so what's
important about metagenomics is that
metagenomics is different from many
other types of omics because it is
trying to characterize a community
instead of an individual
so what this program does
is it is organized into several
different uh sections
we will first cover the logic
why we are trying to ask specific
questions how do we ask specific
questions what are the results that
we're expecting to get then we will talk
about practice how do you practically
try to apply these methods of analysis
and prepare for independence and that
leads us into the project where you can
identify a data set and plan your
analysis and execute it with the help of
technical support
the logic focuses primarily on the
different types of data that
metagenomics covers and the specific
questions that we would be asking using
that data
then the practice leads us into the
specific analytical approaches so that
we understand in detail what are the
types of analyses and what are the
outcomes of those analyses and how do we
know what is significant what is not
significant what is signal and where is
noise
we have to understand that
so in bioinformatics there's an
environment where this kind of an
analysis takes place and that includes
being able to design
sequential uh combinations of code which
are called pipelines and so those
pipelines provide us with the outcomes
that we can then try to interpret
interpret the composition of the
microbiome in the environment how does
the environmental or the gut microbiome
can be associated with behavior can we
look at the gut microbiome the skin
microbiome can we identify associations
with clinical factors etc so leading
from
the very basic understanding of the
logic
all the way to the application where you
can start analyzing specific data sets
and ask these important questions
the program is organized into several
sessions that are separated by the type
of application the type of project or
the type of analysis that you're going
to be doing
now for those of you that might be
completely new to the area of
metagenomics i want to encourage all of
you to try to complete the free
introduction which is called bytes and
molecules on the portal so sonorica
already introduced you to the portal if
you have an account this is a free
course and you will see there that one
of those is an introduction to
metagenomics so in that course you will
be able to understand the terminology
and the specific types of applications
of metagenomics
what we will do is then later on if you
would like to prepare is you can try to
go through the metagenomics data
analysis course and in that course we
cover
data generation types of projects and
data sets and all the way into the
specific analysis and what we will do in
the program is we will actually take a
look at the logic behind the analysis
why these methods were created
how do we apply them what do they
actually produce and we will take a
chance to practice all of these analyses
first of all using our point and click
interface called the t bion4 platform
a good example that i will demonstrate
here in just a second is the data 2
pipeline so the data 2 pipeline is
divided up into several stages
from pre-processing to then
actual uh connecting sort of denoising
what's called denoising data 2 stands
for denoising
and then assignment of taxonomy and
visualization and then we will use this
pipeline to actually understand
different types of visualizations
so let's just briefly take a look
on your portal
on your profile
you will find that with that profile you
should have access to our platform and
this is the link and this platform
combines many of the standard tools that
we typically use for processing and
analysis of data
and if you
follow my example i pasted the link in
the chat you will see that there's a
whole section here dedicated to
metagenomics and that includes three
different sections metagenomics or
microbiome
metagenomics using kind 2 and amplicon
16 has an 18s which looks at
data two and denoising the reads so that
we can assign taxonomy
so in each one of these sections we have
a demo pipeline and the demo pipeline
actually allows us to understand the
analysis
as we build the pipeline
so going through this interface we're
able to actually see how to connect the
individual methods into a pipeline
and
one second
why
this is not loading
okay
let me actually try this again
okay
so after you complete this pipeline you
will also find that there's
visualization that makes it easier to
start looking at the data and
understanding the composition of each
sample comparing the samples in their
proportionate abundance and
understanding the differences between
the different types of
samples that we have using a variety of
statistical and analytical methods so
like here we can see nmds
so in this program and briefly i will
just mention several of the important
kind of aspects of the microbiome
we will learn about microbiome in the
human body including the skin and the
gut or the stomach
where you will understand the different
types of compositions associated with
different kinds of phenotypes we will
look at how these bacteria form
communities and how we can analyze these
communities to understand the
relationship between
a specific phenotype that we can
interpret in a clinical or a phenotypic
way and the actual composition of the
microbes and finally we will look at
collections of data sets where you can
sample
a specific type of samples
to ask questions
so in conclusion this program is going
to give you the tools
and the logic behind the analysis so
that you can be independent in asking
research questions and conducting the
analysis
getting the results that you can publish
or potentially put into a poster
presentation
so with that i will pass on my screen to
dr raghav
and he will talk in greater detail about
the curriculum of this program
[Music]
so america please make him a
co-host he's not a co-host so you cannot
move
thank you very much finally i am of
course thank you very much
and let me get uh my ways to share my
screen
just loading it up for me
okay see my screen no it's still loading
yes i think it should work
can you see my screen
yes
yes thank you very much
so uh thank you alia i'm raghavindran
i'm bioinformatics mentor and research
consultant with biotech and i will take
you
i take this opportunity to welcome all
of you
for this webinar on
meta genomics analysis and study on
microbiome and also
for bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
so we we understood that metagenomics is
a way to study microorganisms in their
natural environment dissecting community
structures exploring species richness
and uh
investigating functional roles of these
microbial communities
functional roles that these communities
or different microbial
communities play in many areas related
to
human health for
human health and diseases
so in this
program actually i will discuss what you
will learn in the upcoming omics logic
metagenomics program that is going to
start by 23rd of may and this online
program will actually cover
main aspects of meta dynamic sequencing
analysis of 16s rrna and other aspects
of
other aspects of metagenomics and
microbiology research using
bioinformatics so at the end of this
program participants will be conducting
independent
or group projects analyzing data mainly
from public domain and to learn
how high impact biomedical publications
are
possible from possible on the microbiome
subjects so let's go over the syllabus
in detail to get an overview on the
variety of different bioinformatics
analysis the logic behind the analysis
and different downstream processing
methods you will be
that you will be introduced to in this
specific program
so we start with an introduction to next
generation sequencing for metagenomic
sequencing and this could include whole
genome sequencing and this could also
include a 16s rrna sequencing
and uh amplicon data types also so we
first start with the overview of tools
and resources that is necessary for this
program like
you will be given an introduction to
various courses projects data sets how
to access uh how to access the
associated resources how to access the
tbio info server platform and how to
get access to different projects and
different
example projects that we are going to
discuss throughout the uh through this
program and then we follow it up with
so this is
yeah we follow it up with uh
an introduction to uh meta genomic
sequencing and its application in
studying microbial community in
functional bacterial uh community
analysis so here we are going to
understand about whole metagenome
sequencing and how to understand or how
to identify different um
different phylogenome or
phyla or different uh variety of
microbial community from the mapping on
to databases like silver and ncbi etc so
we will also deal with different data
formats that is required for performing
such analysis and we will also
understand the flow general flow of meta
genomics pipeline and we will also get a
practical hands-on on variant analysis
in a few bio info server and how to
visualize generally
the mapping and
the mapping of the reads and mapping of
the
of these
leads to the whole genome
reference genome so um
and then we'll we will we will go on to
uh visualize uh sexiness metagenomics
data so here we are going to uh
understand the microbial microbiome
variability using um using amplicon
sequencing and we are going to
also
[Music]
use a 16s rrna
sequencing for the identification of
microorganisms to study microbial
community we will also discuss couple of
uh
data from
human gut
project and also data from acne
or how to understand
the data distribution of active data
from ncbi bio project
and
what follows this is an hands-on project
example on human american vet and human
microbiome
variability so here we will demonstrate
you uh how to how the use of
small subunit rna
sequencing is is performed and is used
for identification of microorganisms and
we will also
introduce you to introduce you to the
definition of gut brain access and
microbiome and and its effect on
behavior of the posts and
and uh and different analysis downstream
analysis methods that can be performed
after the completion of pipeline uh
with the completion of pipeline analysis
on the 16 sampling on data from tbio
info server and then what follows will
be
will be
a will be a detailed uh
project study an example project study
which i will also demonstrate uh show it
to you in the uh in the
in the dynamics logic platform so this
is about meta genomics study on how
how the gut microbiome is affected by a
diet for example a high fat diet and a
normal diet and how
this diet has an in
has an effect and has a has an influence
on
on the behavioral aspects of
a mouse system in this case and you will
also
learn hands-on practice uh
on performing these downstream analysis
in let's say tylosic
using pyroxic library nar
you will also have
different access to different
visualization
different visualization methods that is
used to understand the taxonomic
composition and you will also given
separate space to learn and practice
biologic analysis code in r
it's excuse me it's not responding for a
moment
yes i got it
and then we will
complete the metagenomics courses by
meta genomic courses by culminating into
ah
giving you information about how to plan
a bioinformatic research project so all
that you have learned so far is going to
come and is going to
end up in making you develop your own uh
project from
publicly available data we will we will
show you or we will uh guide you how to
explore and how to extract data from
such big data repositories and how to
carefully
design analysis methods that is traded
for your data and then how to perform
this analysis as you have been learning
throughout the program and then how to
get a
get a good biological interpretation and
how to understand the biology and
different phenotypical characteristics
of the sample that you have been using
for the uh for the project and
throughout the
and through the duration of the program
and for duration of your project what
follows after the program you will have
access to mentors for discussion on your
research progress and you will have
access to mentors and different
different people for troubleshooting
your technical support on regular basis
and you'll also get suggestions and
expert feedback on your progress uh
whenever it is required
so let's uh let me help you or let me
give you an example by showcasing one of
the projects that we recently prepared
on the role of high fat diet on obesity
so before going into what are the
different types of analysis possible
using
possible for such a project let's let me
get give you an overview of uh what is a
gut microbiome and what follows uh the
analysis of microbial community within
the gut microbe so in healthy adults the
gut microbiome exists in a in a in a
state or in a in a mutual symbiosis
state with this host so this environment
of the cut indicates both the
composition and the functional
productivity of the adult gut microbiota
and this gut microbiota may interact
with the host through presentation of
different ligands such as um
such as molecular patterns that are
associated with pathogens and the
different metabolites that are produced
and these different molecules are
responsible and these different
molecules will modulate the immune
system or immune homeostasis of the
gastrointestinal tract and um
and
as you can see in this comparison the
gut microbiome will have an enormous
impact on the life and also on the
status of stages of the
host
so it it plays a fundamental role in
actually shaping the composition
and um and function of the gut and the
way the food is processed and and this
becomes key factor in determining the
amount uh and the type of material that
is
reaching the um
reaching the horse's circulatory system
as um
through the growth and production of
microbiota metabolize so in this
perspective we can see that the um
[Music]
the relationship between symbiosis and
this meiosis of that microbiome in a
healthy individual and an obese
individual will differ ah by their um
by their for example difference in the
uh
variability or different center
in the different uh
types of uh microbiome that is available
or that is that that one observes the
healthy human gut or uh healthy so to
study this uh in this specific project
what was actually performed is uh a
mouse system or mouse model system was
used to do and it was fed a high-fat
diet and a control diet and their
response
to a normal diet and their response to a
high fat diet is studied and
and also
some of the microbiome is actually
transferred from the high fat diet mouse
to the normal diet to understand whether
or not this hyper diet microbiome that
is transferred into a normal microbiome
will influence a behavioral changes to
to to generalize
to learn about what sort of analysis
that can be performed with this
data let me quickly stop share here and
go over to um
and go over to the learnomics project
platform
you will find ways to
where i can show you
if i can find this
okay can you see my screen on project
13.
yes
yes so after performing background
statistical analysis we can
we can get and listen on how to perform
hands-on
how to set up a pipeline for hands-on
analysis of this extremis amplicon
sequencing data so in this
lesson you will
be guided in a step-by-step process
through how to take the raw data and
then how to perform these analysis
pipeline and how to set up the pipeline
and how to perform the pipeline and what
are the different settings that is
required to uh
get the pipeline running and what are
the different outputs uh output files
that we are going to
we are going to uh consider for
downstream analysis and in the
downstream analysis section these major
output files are used to ah perform
downstream analysis using pylosic and
using basic r
uh
tutorial so this
tutorial uh on
uh how to perform downstream analysis on
this applicant data
will include
uh a detail learn the code section where
each and every part of the code has been
explained to you and then what follows
is different data visualization based on
which we can understand what the data
actually tells so here the data tells
the distribution or proportional
abundance of phyla between the hyper
diet and the chow diet is different from
uh different for the two different mice
so that is what you will progressively
see uh when performing this analysis
using ah that is displayed or that is
represented visualize using different uh
visualization so you also will have
access to uh try
how to try yourself these analysis
methods in a special try it yourself
area
let let it load yes where you can learn
from this code and then uh perform these
analysis yourself in the
in the um
try it yourself section so again
this measure of diversity like alpha
diversity beta diversity which will also
tell you how different these two mice
are uh because of the difference in
their proportional abundance uh of uh
microbiome that characterizes their that
uh
so um you will get as i mentioned
a detailed explanation of all possible
uh analysis methods that you can perform
and you'll get a try it yourself section
where you can
try these analysis methods with the
with specific question that is uh
directed to you after learning the
course so with that uh i will actually
pass the stadium to or pass the stage to
earlier
thank you thank you again
yeah thank you
okay so the second topic that we wanted
to discuss today was bioinformatics for
infectious diseases before we go on if
you have any questions throughout the
presentation please feel free to post
them in the chat after the end of this
presentation we'll be able to address
any of your questions so
like selenica mentioned in the very
beginning in this webinar we're going to
be talking about metagenomics but also
program specifically designed to train
those who are interested to apply
bioinformatics and study infectious
diseases so briefly in the next few
minutes we'll talk about this program i
will pass it on to dr ragavendran to
discuss the specific curriculum and
example projects that you'll be able to
work on and then after that we will
finish the webinar by talking about the
summer research
programs that we have planned
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
is really a program designed to address
the pressing need to understand
characterize monitor and address by
intervention the infectious diseases
that are so prevalent and are
characterizing this 21st or 20th uh yeah
21st century so in this program we'll
talk about how to apply
data analysis tools and a lot of them
are going to be somewhat similar to each
other but applied in very different
types of outbreaks epidemics corona
virus ebola virus rhinovirus
tuberculosis malaria so different types
of viral bacterial and other pathogenic
diseases
the program is really designed in a
similar fashion
you will explore relevant topics tools
methods data repositories project
examples
and you'll be able to see how
multi-omics analysis analysis of genomic
transcriptomic proteomic data is going
to inform different types of decisions
about outbreaks
before we jump into this let's briefly
talk about what is the definition of
infectious diseases so infectious
diseases also called communicable
diseases are called by a pathogen and
that pathogen can be a bacteria virus
parasite or fungi and these kinds of
diseases are different from
non-infectious diseases or what's
commonly known as chronic diseases
and so we will actually talk about
specific applications of bioinformatics
to the study of infectious diseases
now in the last couple of years all of
us have been
focused on covid19 and i think really as
a result we kind of
see infectious diseases primarily caused
by viruses but in reality they could be
caused by different types of pathogens
including bacteria that can colonize and
kind of subdue different types of
functions that are important but also
can release toxins and cause organ
failure so in the recent years there
have been a number of pathogens like the
ebola virus in 2014 the outbreak that
brought to the forefront genomic
surveillance of epidemic outbreaks
there have been diseases that have been
affecting millions and millions of
people
and we see
that these diseases actually are not
just the ones that are new like novel
coronavirus but there have been for
centuries like malaria and malaria
affects
a huge amount of people and has been for
many many decades or even centuries
novel
diseases caused by the coronavirus or by
re-emergence of specific diseases are
going to continue and be
you know very important and dangerous
situations that we'll have to address
using such tools now importantly these
kinds of outbreaks are only one type
they are kind of silent and then all of
a sudden there's an outbreak but there
are many viruses that cause or lead to
chronic diseases and so even though we
kind of tend to separate these two
categories there is a quite large
overlap for example epstein-barr virus
and other types of viruses can lead to
cancer
so
in addition to that right beyond viruses
there is a whole field studying
different types of bacteria and for
example
drug resistance microbial or resistant
to antibiotics is a huge concern and so
in this program we're going to talk
about examples in all of these different
fields and importantly we will also talk
about the response to these diseases
that our body already possesses and how
different types of treatments like
vaccines are leveraged to actually
enhance this kind of a
response
so
when we look at the history of
infectious diseases and we look at the
methods to control such outbreaks you
will be surprised to find that actually
vaccines that we talked so much about
today are not not the only ones that
were responsible for the reduced load of
infectious diseases on the population so
from population health perspective we
can see that the establishment of health
departments
actually
municipal use of chlorine and water
use of penicillin
are all
precessors of the vaccines which was
introduced in the 1950s and up until
today
those methods were actually very very
effective
however what happened just recently is
all of a sudden
after having such success with methods
that we already discussed covid19 has
surpassed the mortality of even such
diseases like cancer
and so on one hand we have this dynamic
where we have effective measures that
are quite simple
just washing your hands having chlorine
and water having availability of
antibiotics and then all of a sudden we
see this tremendous
growth of mortality caused by a virus a
virus that has already been studied and
so that leads us to the significance and
the impact of bioinformatics
so in the era of covet 19
not only were we able to analyze that
data quite
rapidly but very quickly we were able to
identify a specific pathogen that then
was tracked almost in real time to
understand how it changes how it evolves
how it starts infecting more and more
people and starting to ask important
questions and the ability to ask those
questions using data that was collected
is the essence of bioinformatics what is
bioinformatics bioinformatics allows us
to leverage these data sets that have
been collected ask specific questions
and get to a practical interpretation so
that we understand something and we're
able to make conclusions
now importantly this pandemic has opened
a number of new questions that are now
being asked and we will see how those
questions are being asked by researchers
that have the expertise to design
experiments or to leverage data that was
collected from others
so here's an example an example where we
can see that we can not only detect a
specific strain of a virus but we can
actually track it over time and
important questions will start to emerge
what is the long-term consequences of 19
how do we monitor and prevent outbreaks
of these infections how do we leverage
our detailed genomic characterization of
the virus or the pathogen and introduce
a very specific targeted therapy that
can prevent or
kind of make it less dangerous
so with this brief introduction i will
again pass on the stage to dr raghav to
speak about the specifics and examples
that are relevant for this upcoming
program
and
answer any questions that you might have
about what are the outcomes of such
training so over to you dr raghav
thank you very much elia let me again
find the search on the screen
so hello once again so
in this session we are going to
discuss about how different or various
big data bioinformatics analysis methods
will will actually help you in
understand the bioinformatics of
infectious diseases and we will also in
addition to discussing the application
of different bioinformatics analysis
methods this program will also show you
uh several examples of these analysis
methods that are used in pathogen
diagnostics in evolutionary studies of
the virus and
in the discovery of antiviral drugs and
vaccines and the design of antiviral
vaccines as well as um to characterize
emerging drug resistance across
across the different pathogens so let's
go over this
briefly go over the syllabus briefly so
by the end of the program you will be
able to explore relevant tools for
characterizing sequence variation and
sequence alignment at the whole genome
level you will be able to learn from
peer reviewed publications and example
projects about how phylogenetic analysis
helped in understanding the emergence
and spread of pandemic lycovide and
epidemic like ebola viruses so you will
also be able to master key analysis
methods and visualization tools
that are related to sequence variation
with functional properties of the
protein and
these tools will help you understand the
mutations that are critical for the
pathogenicity and are critical for the
functioning of the pathogens
you will also get an introduction to
study the host's response by analyzing
the transcriptomics data of the infected
host compared to the healthy host so we
can also understand how actively the
host is
responding to the pathogen or to the
infection in this case
so we will start again with
with an introduction to next gen
sequencing and we will discuss about
various ngs sequencing methods and we
will discuss about different data
formats that used in the sequencing
genome whole genome sequencing data and
we will discuss about exploring
exploring the
tbio info server and exploring
visualization of the uh
reads that are mapped onto the whole
genome sequence in this case vital
sequence or pathogens sequence using a
visualization tool such as a j browser
and etc
then we will follow this up with
understanding
follow this up with
getting an introduction to multiple
sequence alignment methods and
phylogenetic tree analysis to understand
the viral adaptations and the mutations
that are characterizing the different
pathogens so we will also work with an
example projects and examples of
deadly mutations in ebola and how that
translates into
different
virulence or different
effects of pathogenic effects of ebola
virus so we will also get to compare
multiple sequences at amino acid level
at nucleotide level and also compare
different methods for constructing
phylogenetic analysis will visualize the
phytogenetic three and ferrogenetic tree
results using specific software
that is available for tree analysis and
also for uh understanding multiple
sequence alignment methods
so in this
hands-on session this will be a combinat
this will be a follow-up hands-on
session to the session that you studied
before and
discussed before so where
you will be shown how to build a
pipeline so that you can perform
multiple sequence alignment of viral
genomes and a phylogenetic tree analysis
using different phylogenetic methods so
you will also be given um
an introduction to different analysis
pipelines uh like selecting appropriate
genomic sequences and selecting uh
different pipeline
methods that is suited for either fast q
files or suited for faster files
so we will also uh analyze the output
discuss the pipeline results and analyze
uh
how to perform the downstream analysis
of the pipeline outputs and what to do
if we have a fasta file and pass profile
for input and we will also understand
which databases to use to
uh to gather uh in
to gather information regarding the
viral sequences and we will also see how
to interpret the phytogenetic tree
analysis that is uh that is the result
of different different phylogenetic
three methods and how to understand the
evolutionary relationships between the
genomes in terms of evolutionary time in
terms of mutation and in terms of uh
birth and death of different strains
that are um yeah that are
with the varying degree of pathogenicity
and then from there we will go to uh
understand how viral transmission occurs
uh across
and we will take this or we will
understand with the help of ebola virus
and what are the
specific insights we
learned from studying the epidemic of
ebola which is as clearly i mentioned as
one of the first epidemic that is
studied or that is real time track using
next generation sequencing data and we
will also understand the origins of
these viral adaptations and we will also
extend this analysis to novel
coronavirus genome sequence so that we
can compare uh
the
novel corona virus
source 2 viral sequence with the other
related viral sequences
and we will get a good introduction to
how the disease progresses once the
virus
infects the host so
what happens and what are the functional
domains of different uh
proteins for uh that
for example spike proteins and different
proteins that are uh
involved in uh involved in the
disease progression and involved in
helping the virus getting access into
the cellular
different cellular
cytosol and how this virus
uses or hijacks the hosts
cellular mechanisms to
enable its own progression and we will
also understand uh understand how this
how the disease how the
pathogen uh
evades the immune response of the host
system
in this session
and then what follows is a hands-on
session of an example project and this
example project will compare uh the
sars2 whole genome sequence with the
other
with the other related viral sequence of
sars
mers and other
to understand how
how
how related sars to novel coronavirus
whole genome sequence is with the other
viral sequences we will also take uh
search to uh sequence from different
hosts so that we can understand the
zoonotic origin of source 2 and how
surge 2 is related to
for example um two different parts of
such two how it is
related to
different hosts like from bad from
pangolin etc
and then we will also understand the uh
understand how to
analyze the mutation
mutation types and how to analyze
different mutation types like synonymous
mutation distance mutation
non-synonymous mutation and how to
calculate the weight of this mutation
and
how to map these mutation rates
onto the spike protein for example or
onto the protein so that we can get and
get a visualization or hands-on
visualization or exploring
exploring the protein structures
and
that is color coded or that is mapped
font for the mutation rate at that is
different position so we will use uh
ucsf camera
and
softwares like camera camera x and pymol
for this specific visualization
and then we will also understand uh
understand what are the different low
frequency mutation and how will they
actually enable the virus to maintain
its virulence and what are the different
annotations
on what are the different locations on
genome and proteome
genome and put different protein
that is uh that contains these mutations
and how uh it relates to the
accumulation of mutation only on the
specific areas of for example spike
protein and other related proteins so
that the uh virus adapts itself to
maximize its virulence and remain fit in
the
evolutionary pressure
so
finally we will also understand the host
side or whose response to such
pathogenic
pathogenic
infection so we will get an uh we will
get an introduction to
transcriptomics data analysis we will
get an introduction to what is measured
from the post side and
how we can perform a comparative rna-seq
pipeline analysis so that we can uh
identify key
responses from the host site for the
pathogenic interaction so we can
understand uh how
different uh for example
healthy hoes and infected hosts differ
in terms of their immune response and
what are the different factors for
considering vaccine design when
after identifying a specific host
response and pathways
so
uh this
program will also culminate in helping
you to design a bioinformatics research
and bioinformatics research project
you will be uh you'll be able to choose
a topic for
for your project and then again you will
be uh
explained where to extract data for for
example uh related to infectious
diseases and related to uh specific
viral repositories and then um we will
also get a lot of hands-on
training on how to perform these
analysis over the course of program that
you can apply onto your own target so i
i want to highlight
three related publications that is uh
that is published in 2022 and uh with
the available number of public with
available number of
data that is deposited in the public
repositories uh for coding and this
program and these analysis methods will
enable you to learn or when it will
enable you to understand uh how these
studies are performed and then you can
generate your own research question in
the very relevant pandemic era and
which still
helps you to understand different
aspects of starscope to infection and
and how big data bioinformatics is
generally uh helping us tracking this
pandemic and also preparing us for any
future attacks in the uh in the upcoming
years so
we all know how uh source code to data
the rich data has enabled understanding
the
different
variants of concern or variance of
interest what are the different
relationship between these variants and
how uh in real time how these phylogen
dynamics is being tracked and how these
how these different variants are related
to each other and we also can get an
introduction to how the virus actually
enables itself for how this virus
actually has an intra host variation uh
level that is not being explored in
detail
previously so to get a scale of to get
an understanding of uh
on the scale of genomes uh that is being
tracked with the
with the um
with the kovid19 response so within a
month of uh within a month of infection
uh we we got almost an ah an average of
one thousand three hundred genomes were
being submitted to uh ncbi and being
submitted to desired uh database uh per
day regularly and within the six months
of start of the pandemic uh
gizzard had almost like 110
000 full-length star scope 2 genome
sequences so by the end of december by
the end of 2021 two years into the
pandemic we had 67 000 genomes that were
deposited to the public vital genome
depositories per day daily so currently
the repositories like
giza genbank ncbi
virus and cog uk everything all of these
combined to
contain over 6 million star spoke to
genomes
in its entirety so we can see where
the palo genetic studies and different
surveillance studies are performed all
over the world and
and irrespective of different uh
different continents all the continents
contribute to
tracking this viral pandemic in real
time and that that is possible
mainly through the analysis of big data
analysis of the next generation
sequencing data and that has enabled us
to understand and also keep exploring
the data for future patterns and for
further patterns that is uh that is uh
so rich in in its variety and and uh
throwing as lot of surprises so one of
that is uh one of the surprise or one of
the
key discovery is the
in-host diversity of this virus or its
ability to
adapt itself to inhost
within the hosts
based on the host response so this what
this means this means that
the viral
in the viral sequences that that for
example that causes severe symptoms or
whose virulence has
has an increased rate of virulence
has a different variation compared to
the
virus whose virulence has mild symptoms
so
understanding this imposed diversity
will pave way for us to arrest this
development or this increase in the
virulence factor of this virus and
thereby even if the virus spreads from
the host to um to the inter-host or
different
to the the different individual we can
actually make sure that not the most
virulent virus is going to
spread and going to cause
infection for the other diseases so we
also get an um get an overview in uh
in what is being currently studied and
what is being clinically valued in in
the current pandemic scenario for
example we value a lot on
genomics and transcriptomics data only
about the source code and from the
viruses point of view mostly
the genomics data is what has been
considered
really informative but we have a whole
plethora of or mixed data from the host
and also from the
viral
from the pathogens responses which can
be
integrated into a
big multi-omic studies and that aspect
of this
infectious disease
scenario
pandemic scenario has not been explored
in detail so far so there are still a
lot of opportunities there to develop
methods that will effectively integrate
for example the host response to the
pathogens and also the virulence levels
of the pathogens to the
host response to study how these two ah
how these two uh
partner in it in the
effective
transmission of the virus so uh
we have uh
we have not even touched about how uh
how or what are the long-term effects of
for example kovitt infection so uh into
the third year of the pandemic and
we we have uh still a lot of data that
can be studied for example uh for the
symptoms that prevail uh what happens
after one year or two years of uh
tears of the infection already there are
studies that uh
that that
try to characterize the fatigue level
that try to characterize the um they try
to characterize the
loss of smell and taste level of the
host individual after several weeks and
several months of uh
kovid infection so
this panda make and also this infection
has actually thrown up a lot of
opportunities which are being currently
explored at the different degree and
under the increased rate and this
program will enable you to first
understand and dissect all of these
analysis methods and then develop
an analysis method for your own for a
different dataset so that we can
understand the biology of these
infectious diseases or you can
understand apply these methods to uh
to another disease of your interest and
and
and gain lot of
experience in the bioinformatics
analysis of input sources
so with that i will
attend some of the questions if you have
any
and pass this stage back to
sonalika aurelia
yes if you are there you could maybe
describe some of the other summer
programs
yes
thank you so much dr raka
and i'll now quickly share my screen
first of all and uh
take you all through the registration
process for the two programs that we
have discussed and then we can go
through the summer programs as well and
if you have any questions please put
them in the chat so that we can answer
them or we also stay back after the
meeting is over and take your queries
yes so talking about the infectious
diseases program here is the link to the
program page in the chat box
now how do you register yourself and
where do you find these resources that
discuss today about the social schedule
as well so visit the program page and if
you scroll down you can see that
is a calendar where you can see the
dates for the scheduled sessions and
also the details about each and every
session
so you can see the title and the topics
that will be covered and along with each
and every session you are supposed to go
through some of the resources now these
resources are actually the the lessons
on the surgical and portal to which
you'll get an access to as a part of the
program and along with each session you
are supposed to go through the session
recording of the session that would be
uploaded on the program page once the
session is uh complete and also you need
to go through the associated resources
and uh on the date of the session you
can see a complete session item that you
need to click on to complete a
particular session and you need to
follow the same practice for each and
every session that is mentioned on the
program page
so that was about the schedule and of
what we are going to cover for each and
every session and also the associated
online resources i'll shortly take you
through these lessons and show you how
they look like we have a question in the
chat box so i'll just
pause for a second
uh yes you can definitely register uh
for the summer program after 27th may
uh so these programs are going to run
asynchronously if in case you are not
available before 27th and you want to do
it later on you can definitely enroll
the programs would be active till july
31st and you can go through the
asynchronous session recordings and also
the resources on the portal and we'll
connect you with the mentors via slack
channel where you can clarify your
questions anytime
uh karthika for the metagenomics course
the timings of the sessions would the
live q a sessions would be around 10 am
cst that would be 8 30 pm isd and in
case you are not available for the live
q a sessions we can take your questions
in a separate meeting as per your
availability and you can go through the
session recordings as i said at your own
pace as the recordings would be
available on the program page itself
for the slack channel we are going to
share the url uh the link basically the
link of each and every slide channel uh
with you once you are registered you
will get the link to the slack channel
you can then join the slack channel
where the mentors are also a part of
these groups and clarify questions
yes definitely basundra we do work on
research projects that you can
work on and get published in repetitive
journals we can discuss about the
research fellowship program as well but
just shortly once i'm done with the
registration for infectious diseases
program metagenomics and discuss these
summer programs as well
all right so coming back to infectious
diseases um registration page now scroll
down and you will be able to find three
different subscription levels now now
what are these so you have three levels
here beginner intermediate and advanced
now in the beginner's level you will get
the access to such live sessions and
also the resources definitely the
resources access to all of the resources
remains the same it just varies on the
type of
mental guidance that you that you will
be getting throughout the program in the
intermediate session you will be getting
the access to one on one live
sessions with the mentor as well and uh
taking the advanced subscription will
help you work on your research proposal
like you can go through the program and
then have a live session a live meet
with your mentor and discuss
about your research question and have a
proposal in hand that you can further
work on in your research uh like as a
research project and definitely have an
outcome either get it published or
present your work in a post or
presentation competition in um the
conferences or symposium as we mentioned
we are going to have a symposium in the
month of august as well so you can
definitely present your work in an
international symposium like that and
many of you have a criteria to also
submit your project if you are a student
to submit your dissertation work in your
college so yes that uh thing would be
justified with the advanced level of
subscription
so that was about infectious diseases uh
program now one thing that i would like
to mention here you can simply click on
the select option button and then
proceed with the payment gateway in case
you are um in a country uh where you are
not able to proceed further with the
select option icon you can reach out to
us and we have sparked her here present
as well in the meeting and uh you can
reach out to her at marketing other at
omixlogic.com
can you please put your details in the
chat box and she'll be able to assist
you with the alternate options that you
can choose to get yourself enrolled so
you will have a smooth enrollment
process will ensure that
and now let's talk about the
metagenomics program
so the link is in the chat here
thank you spash for sharing your email
address and also sparsh has shared the
contact number uh
that is active in india so if you are in
india you can call her and um
clarify any of the questions that you
might have
all right so talking about metagenomic
data analysis program
uh similarly you can also look at the
schedule the session schedule of the
program on the program page of
metagenomics data analysis and for each
and every session we have mentioned the
topics that would be covered and also
the associated resources the lessons
that you're supposed to go through these
lessons consist of the course material
which includes the content it also uh
includes the guidelines to run various
pipelines on the be bioinfo server that
you should try to practice yourself and
also get your outputs and understand how
to interpret these outputs to
extract some meaningful biological
insights
and similarly we have all the session
details for each and every session
present here on the program page and to
enroll for this particular program you
need to uh pick any of these
subscription levels uh the criteria
remains the same for beginner
intermediate and advanced level you pick
the level that works best for you and
yeah that's pretty much uh how you can
enroll yourself for the program
now i would uh like to um pass it on to
uh spash so that she can clarify
questions and then we will look at uh
more of the summer programs that that we
would be having in the month of june
so splash over to you
uh so hello everyone i am sparsh and i'm
working as business development
associate at find biotech
regarding the resist registration steps
as uh sunalika said that if anyone who
is not able to proceed with the payment
checkout with the select option
so we can specifically send them an
invoice directly on their mail id or we
have specific upi ids for indian
contacts
so as to make the payments more visible
also we have bank transfer details for
both outside india as well as for indian
interested uh contacts
so uh those who are facing who will be
facing any difficulty while enrolling
themselves for the program for
metagenomic data analysis or for the
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
can uh contact me on marketing at the
reykjavikslogic.com
or i have provided with you the contact
information it is active on whatsapp
also
so uh you can connect with me via
whatsapp
uh as well as indian and outside the
indian contact uh also so i'll be there
to help you and assist you out if still
you have any questions related you can
uh
simply write down in the chat box and
i'll be there to assist you with
thank you
so much
and do we have any questions for sparsh
if you are interested to enroll in the
program and if you have any questions
you can please ask her
yes anna you can definitely
switch over to the research fellowship
program to continue and publish your
work once you have your research
question in hand
all right so if we have no more
questions for okay we have a question
uh these all programs are scheduled and
it is there on the omixlogic learn
portal
avinash so um
if i'll just show you when you visit the
omni logic learn portal there's a tab
called programs over here so you need to
just click on the programs tab and you
will find a list of these programs
ongoing upcoming and you can explore
them and if you click on any of these
programs then you'll be able to learn
more about it
all right so with this now i would like
to tell you also about uh the programs
which you can join asynchronously
anytime so one of these is
transcriptomic data analysis program and
the link to the page is
here i put in the chat box uh spurs can
you please put your uh number once again
but sundara wants it can you put in the
chat box thank you
all right and similar to the pages that
i showed you before this page uh also
works the same way where you can look at
the session details for each and every
session and uh then pick up the
subscription level that you would like
to pick and enroll for it and the next
program that i would like to discuss
about is the genomic data analysis
program that you can also enroll in any
time um
along the summer and
leverage from it now on the page itself
you will find the session details once
again and also to enroll you can scroll
down and pick the subscription level
that works the best for you
now as many of you uh discussed and
asked also about the research fellowship
program so what is this program all
about and like what is the structure of
the program for how many months can you
enroll what outcome can you expect by
enrolling the particular research
fellowship program
you can find all these details here on
the program page so uh
if you are a student and you are looking
forward to do your internship for a two
months um
time period which actually starts from
june or to july maybe or july to august
um as per uh your universities or
institutions guidelines then you can
join the two months research fellowship
program but uh it will it is more
feasible to join the three months or the
six months research fellowship program
so that you you can get better outcomes
so in the two months of the research
of the research fellowship program it
would be possible for you to do a proper
literature review and then also work on
your research project with some
preliminary data analysis but a
three-month research fellowship program
uh would be most uh structured where you
will also get to finalize your uh
research as a poster and present as i
told before as well you can present your
poster in any of the conferences and
symposiums and if you are dedicated to
get a publication out of your research
project then definitely six months time
period would be the best for you where
you can validate your results work on
your manuscript with the mentor and
finally uh look for a good journal where
you can publish it and go through the
process that is required
and to learn more about the mentors of
the research fellowship program you can
visit the page here and also on the page
itself you will be able to look at some
of the research fellows presentations
and also to look at the project
submissions by some of our research
fellows i'll show you the exact place
where you can go and also look at these
project presentations that came out very
beautifully uh by our research fellows
and they were able to publish their
project on our portal so if you go to
the pro omix logic learn portal and
click on the project stamp you'll be
redirected to all these projects which
um
were put together by our research
fellows these research fellows were from
amity university uh amity university
campuses india uh and also a lot of them
were from various uh universities in the
year in the uh in us africa china and
you can go through their project
publications and learn more about how
this program works and what type of
outcome is it possible for you to have
as well
so very briefly i have tried to mention
about the whole research fellowship
program but if you're interested to
learn more about the whole structure how
it exactly works uh what is your
research interest if you want to tell us
and then if you uh want to understand
how the whole training process and the
research part will work for you in this
program then please feel free to reach
out to us we can have a one-on-one meet
maybe where we can um make you
understand the whole process and align
it as per your research interest
uh gizelle the link for genomic data
analysis
is
here in the chat
all right so do we have any more
questions